jean pierre descombes le doigt sur la
bouche
notre invité pourquoi quand on connaît
sa voix et voici tout d'abord bien sûr
l'accessoire indispensable le petit
sifflet ont par contre attention voilà
nos amis ils sont masqués pas encore
après ce que voilà c'est fini c'est fini
ces frais patrick topaloff triche oui il
à m'acheter un oeil là donc patrick
topaloff a mis ses lunettes par régis et
moustache c'est fait moustache à la
moustache rejoint le match que ça fait
un ensemble assez très bien vous comment
rouler cher jean pierre pendant tout de
suite un petit essai avec les siffleurs
pour dire oui on s'y fait une fois non
deux fois et dit oui ni non du lait que
lui voilà voilà ce que ça donne bon eh
bien nous sommes prêts les i questionnée
oui mais moustache michelin
j'ai joué toute l'année on va monter le
charlot ah ça y est vous danseurs non
vous êtes un homme ou une femme est ce
que vous êtes un homme on security dans
le doubs et c'est peut-être un petit
enfant non plus non c'est un gars
autonome le reconnaît là c'est le plein
oui quand même bien à
est ce que vous faites dans le drame
monsieur
enfin l'acteur sérieux à leur demande
bah je sais pas moi je ne sais plus j'ai
tout est ce que je vous connais quoi
qu'il en soit ça veut dire très bien
aussi oui multiplier à la mairie
oui est ce que vous connaissez tous est
ce qu on vous connaît tous vous êtes
célèbre musée c'est beaucoup c'est
tellement d'eau elle vaut actuellement à
monter le cal pour le festival de la
télé il aurait donc une prestation là
bas avez-vous le principal rôle c'est
carbet je vois pas du tout
est ce que vous êtes jeunes ouais ils
modulent toujours je suis malade je vous
dis toi monsieur c'est le titre de
monsieur a battu connais personnellement
réimpression est-ce que cela y en a chez
nous que nous est ce que nous devons
vous risque on vous connaît
personnellement oui mais
on connaît pas la team des jo mais
qu'est-ce que j'ai chanté aussi monsieur
à venir avec les musiciens oui à moins
qu'ils disent oui mais vous n'êtes plus
il ya aussi ça veut dire à catégoriser
ces catégories vous êtes sportif aussi
ouais voilà qui modulent vraiment bien
vous pratiquer un sport d équipe
l'inventeur d'une chorale peut-être
parce qu'on traîne laissés dans le noir
à cette demande est là elle va avoir
donné des noms comme ça mais sottement
vous êtes bien obligé d'étaler pour
l'attique le brasier pas c'est pas très
drôle toit de rien serieys toi car des
clauses bras c'est non c'est paris non
non j'ai pas vu on a droit à un sac à la
télé
alors là il est temps de donner un nom
au moins c'est pas la suite dans les
idées
parle-nous moi j'vais non non non non
non je vais lui offrir le sifflet
d'ailleurs bien ça ne sera que justice
or allégé décision une décision il va
gardois comtois n'ont pas dit non je n'y
arrive alors françois françois son
nouveau et micheline bon alors c'est
terminé s'est terminé bien vous pouvez
enlever mon match j'ai regardé puisqu'on
a enlevé au mali
non bien sûr j'ai sifflé comme thème
michenaud absolument pas écoute chéri
enfin à et je viens de te voir et que
j'étais trop petit un pic et que ça veut
dire ça ah non c'est non non non je les
tenais site ou bien comment allez-vous
mai aps les agneaux bas bien moi
maintenant ben oui moi aussi je suis
bien content tu peux que ça m'ennuyait
de sifflet j'avais envie de te dire tout
l'amour et tout et tout rien rien m moi
j'ai senti tout avait l'air chaud que tu
veux faire avec un truc en poussant à ce
que tu fais actuellement à monte carlo
et bien parce que là j'ai eu des films
qui sont passées qu'ils ont des
sélectionnés le bartleby réalisée par
maurice ronet adaptée par jean poiret c
est maurice ronet et puis le film de
jacques ertaud la mer promise qui est
passé également le même jour c'est à
dire mardi dernier et puis alors
maintenant on attend des résultats
c'était très très bien accueillis alors
c'est pour ça je suis un montagnard et
ça me fait très très plaisir parce que
il fait beau avec un rien un petit un
petit air frais mais très très très beau
s'est fait très beau voile alors
je connaissais chantal je connais ses
sandales de vue mais bon je ne vous en
dis pas plus mais je ne tiens pas ce que
chantal intentions orientale elle et
elle est vraiment extraordinaire on
pense bien l'image aller quelles
promesses et brochets des projets et
bien les projets et les chanteurs non
bah ça j'aimerais bien mais enfin pour
l'instant rien n'est pas la fin les
fiançailles sont en route et sur le plan
de la de la pellicule et bien il y a
une probablement une série de gérard cyr
avec maurice closs une série de six
films
qui vont s'appeler l'homme
les hommes de roses des hommes de rose
prénom rose on va bientôt dans l'équipe
des jeux de 20 heures
ah bah ça j'espère aussi ma place est
toujours la même la base d'accords
d'accord comment tu vas mongongu ça j
entends je t'ai pas vu ma confiance nous
très bien monsieur thapa la fin mon
grand comment tu vas m'ont pas toi je
veux bien manger bien content de voir m
aussi ça me fait bigrement plaisir parce
que ça fait justement coop michel jeury
vu un petit peu avant mais là ça me fait
spécialement plaisir parce que moustache
et pas de topalov ça fait un petit
moment je n'avais pas vu morrison garde
sa place au chaud maître capello tu
attends aussi avec dacquois toujours en
forme et la merci mon avis tu as gagné
tu veux gagner 50 francs pour un jeune
garçon il s'appelle eric il est là il
est tout à derrière la côte est voilà
bah bravo eric on le peut l'appeler non
il est pas là non non il est derrière
dans la foule on le verra après
démission alors il a gagné 50 francs les
bains je suis très content va le
partager les quotités rico salut à tous
salut